first and foremost happy pride
happy bride
what an exciting month but we celebrate
pride all year round at et canada as we
should listen congratulations on queers
folk
i had just re-watched the us version
maybe about three months ago when i knew
this was coming out soon i re-watched
that and i
now feel like i'm heading into this
just with a new respect for this
reimagining of it it is diverse
it is just beautiful set in new orleans
it is an incredible show congratulations
to both of you
my earliest memories growing up and
watching as folk is being
the
kid on the couch and hearing footsteps
and changing the channel as my parents
or sibling were coming into the room
because i of course was not out um but
it was such a powerful show for me to
watch devin what was your relationship
with queer's folk oh my relationship was
very similar except i was in my early
20s um you know it was it was very much
still the uh what's done in the dark
will come to the light type situation
and so i'm so excited that uh what i did
in the dark which was watch the show now
it's come to the light and i get to be a
part of it so
it's so crazy and johnny same question
to you i know you were a fan and when
you first heard that this was kind of in
the works
you really wanted to be a part of this
and yeah
look at you now you are starring on
queer as folk no honestly like this is
the like
you put something out to the universe
and sometimes it just happens and you
are so perfect in this show in this role
so congratulations i love you both of
you are incredible but johnny what was
your relationship with queer as folk
yeah i mean i was exactly like you it's
so it's crazy that the like it feels
like the queer experience when we were
younger with queers folk was so similar
so mine was very much the same and then
i think it was in 2018 when i heard
there like might be rumblings of like a
reboot or reimagining i was i like wrote
a tweet on twitter i was like who would
you guys cast in this and like obviously
no one said me because i wasn't you know
a name then but um but i remember when
it they started casting i like texted my
team i'm like i have to be in this no
matter what i can be a janitor in the
background um so flash forward to me
sitting here with you today is kind of i
did get goosebumps when you said that
because it is crazy how we you know have
these dreams and then sometimes they
come true and um yeah it's just and
especially with this show specifically
it feels like such a privilege to be
part of this new iteration
i mentioned that the show was set in new
orleans which is i've been a few times
and it is just
such a magical city i feel like there's
nothing like it that i've ever
experienced so devin why do you think
that new orleans was the perfect place
for a show like queer as folk to be set
oh i think it was it's it was amazing
because new orleans house is this spirit
of
um like revival you know like no other
city that i know of goes through so much
like pain and destruction and has forced
to rebuild on the regular you know and
so when you go to the city like you said
you've experienced um it is such this
my my projection was that it was going
to be this like broken down broken sad
mosquito-filled place and it's not you
know it is very like they find a reason
to celebrate and that mirrors our show
so perfectly you know it's this group of
people who do go through something
tragic and then we find reasons to
celebrate and rebuild and so we couldn't
have made the show without that city
because the spirit of the city is
is really embodied in what we created
definitely and you mentioned you know
the tragic event and of course there is
a
pulse like shooting in this series that
happens at babylon and i imagine johnny
reading the script um
i feel like these things are triggering
for queer people because there is so
much violence within the queer community
so as you read that script was there a
moment of like
pressure that you felt to capture the
emotions that queer people go through
when there is a violent thing like a
shooting which obviously has occurred
and there's violence across the board
daily for queer people
yeah i mean for me when i read the
script for the first time i was like in
bed and i was so excited because these
stories were being told and then it
happened and i just remember being like
no
you know like audibly upset and you know
it took me a second to be like we have a
responsibility as queer people and as
queer artists to honor the truth of what
it is that we go through as a community
and i know a lot of people are like no
we don't want to see trauma we don't
want to see but it is it's not the
trauma that we are uh dealing with it's
what comes the phoenix that rise out of
the ashes because as queer people that
is just baseline who we are we are it's
not about what we go through it's about
what we get through and i feel like um
you know and all of the the stories that
have come before even this of uh you
know queer people that have gone through
things is super important to honor that
but also honor how special we are
because of the things that we go through
yeah absolutely and listen there is the
trauma but there's also so much queer
joy in this series and that is something
that i love about it so much because i
feel like all too often when we are
dealing with queer stories it is often
a lot of trauma um on screen and that is
a part of our stories kind of like you
mentioned johnny but you know there's
also just this joy of being queer i woke
up today on pride month and i'm like
my life would be
so different if i was not queer like it
is the biggest blessing and when i was
younger i didn't see it that way and
that's the beautiful thing about being
queer is you grow and learn to
you know love who you are so showing
that queer joy on screen devin must just
be so much fun for you there's so many
great scenes that you have i love your
characters so much um but to kind of
show that being queer is also fun is
that important for you oh it's
joy is my number one if i had a
personality trait it would literally
just be joy it's true all right so
um so i was i was so excited to just get
to be funny and sarcastic and like
ev make everything a joke because that's
what we do when we go through hard
things like that's how i feel like i
developed my personality was going
through things you know and so like
making everything a joke and like having
having joy it's i mean it's necessary
it's what we need in this world is to
learn how to heal through laughter
definitely uh two queer icons i'm
calling them icons because i feel like
they are in my life juliette lewis and
kim catrell come on
incredible tell me first and foremost
she's canadian kim cattrall what was it
like having her on set
i mean
it's it's surreal just because kim is
one of those people i i definitely grew
up watching and being like wow that is a
powerhouse of confidence um and then you
meet her and she is exactly that but
she's so soft-spoken and kind i remember
uh we like all got crocs at the
beginning of of our filming and i
remember giving her crocs
yeah
and what was her what was her response
was she like she was like
and i swear she talks just like this
she's like oh my gosh i haven't even
done anything yet and i was like you've
done so much you have no idea take the
crocs um
but yeah it's just she is and and juliet
as well they're both just so kind and
sweet and so damn good at their jobs
like it it makes you realize like oh
this is why they've been doing it for
for this long and well for this long
yeah absolutely and finally just to wrap
things up you know the other versions of
queers folk were
you know
called out for being
very white
and also having you know not a lot of
representation so this version i feel
like
is just such a natural progression of
where we are in media and as queer
people it is showing people across the
board and that includes you know
disabilities non-binary trans there's
this beautiful world out there so for
both of you to be part of this series
that is really of the now and showing so
many people out there that
everybody can be part of this community
and everybody is accepted as part of the
queer community is that just the best
part for both of you
yeah i think it it is like you know that
i just got goosebumps you saying that
because we've always existed all of
those all of those people that you just
uh talked about have always existed
within the community so it's really
really special to be able to
see ourselves in the way that we exist
already in the world um you know and
then and then not also know that there's
still more room to grow and still more
stories to tell and all of our stories
are are just a piece of what you can you
know find if you go out to any bar in
you know anywhere in in the us
something i like to focus on is like how
important the first two iterations were
to so many people and they only included
this much you know so now that we've
broadened the spectrum it's like
well how important is this going to be
you know how many more people are going
to get to see it and have the exact same
connection that so many people had to
the original two-seater and so it's like
wow
wow wow well i can tell you it's gonna
be monumental it really is
congratulations to both of you i am such
a fan of both of you in the show i see
big things for both of you it has been a
pure pleasure to chat with both of you
hopefully some time in person thank you
so much for making this series and
thanks for being cool
you